[Music]
here's your money briefing for Friday
March 24th I'm J.R Wellen for the Wall
Street Journal
as pandemic restrictions eased and
offices open back up companies embraced
the idea of employees working a hybrid
schedule but now some companies that
once praised remote working frown upon
it and it's raising tensions between
companies and their workers wsj
columnist Callum Borchers looked into
this issue in his latest on the clock
column and he joins me now hey Callum
thanks very much for being with us glad
to be with you Jr you know Callum most
offices have opened up by now but the
ability to work remotely or at least
work a hybrid schedule that's pretty
much become a way of life for many
employees it certainly has and it's not
something that they're willing to give
up easily Jr because of course the essay
on the commute time maybe you don't have
to pay for parking there's a lot of
conveniences that come with being able
to work from home and so we do still see
a really high demand for workers to have
this flexibility and at the same time we
see some companies kind of souring on
this idea for a few reasons but wasn't
it not long ago when we saw companies
touting kind of a checkerboard schedule
you know maybe three days in the office
two days at home what's caused that to
shift right and remember some of the
reasons the company said they liked it
was well we could recruit Talent from
all over the place right that's going to
be a recruiting Advantage for us if
we're not just focused on the local
market but now of course one thing
that's changed is the labor market
starting to cool off there's a lot of
talk of a possible recession and because
of that some companies aren't in the
same growth mode that they were at this
time six months ago or a year ago and so
the recruiting Advantage is less of an
enticement instead they're focused more
on efficiency that's sort of the
buzzword that we keep hearing come up at
a lot of these companies it sounds like
there are strong arguments on both sides
of this issue it is and it's something
that companies were willing to tolerate
when they felt like there was enough of
a payoff but right now some managers are
telling me they're getting kind of sick
of it and of course to be fair I mean
there are plenty of bosses too who
really never liked this remote idea it
was something they felt they had to give
as an allowance to workers when the
labor market was that it's very very
tightest yeah and you spoke to some
company leaders who are dealing with
this redrawing of work rules how's that
going well they tell me they're getting
some resistance from their teams as you
might guess a fella named Alan Jones
comes to mind he's the founder and CEO
of an HR company in La called Bambi he's
got about 175 employees they're not all
local but most of them are and he said
look I gathered the team recently and
told them I'm inclined to bring you all
back five days a week I think that's
really the way that we'll work the best
and he said the team was up in arms
people did not like that idea so he's
basically made a deal where he said all
right we'll do three days in the office
and I'll preserve two work from home
days and I'll even throw in a third one
over the summer if you can keep it but
you got to show me the productivity
doesn't drop off and so this experiment
has been going on for a while and
unfortunately what he reports to me is
that when it comes to signing up new
subscribers for their software and HR
Management Service it's common to see a
30 dip on the days when everybody is at
home so right now he's looking at the
numbers and saying this isn't working
really well it's kind of confirming my
suspicions so wait the chance to work
from home and enjoy Summer from the
backyard that might not happen it may
not I said to him Allen so what are the
chances here that you're actually going
to get these summer Fridays at home and
he said well I don't want to preempt
anything I would say to the team so he
wouldn't tell me what the timeline is I
take it there's maybe a little bit more
of an improvement period a little more
Runway it is still just March but I
think that you know come summer if folks
want to be working from home on Fridays
they really need to crank up the effort
I think one of the things that I heard
from managers was it really is kind of
an effort issue in their minds and they
feel like people had maximum effort at
the height of the pandemic partly
because it was this sort of acute moment
it was a global crisis a lot of
companies were fail feeling that was
sort of a special lightning in a bottle
thing is the way Mr Jones put it to me
but it's hard to sustain that over the
Long Haul and now there's a bigger
sample size you see some Business
Leaders saying we're just not as
productive as we were two years ago now
Callum a moment ago you mentioned the
recruiting of workers the opportunity to
work remotely emerged as a Hallmark of
the fierce competition among companies
over the past two years to bring in
workers where do things stand now yeah
this is a great measurable Jr because it
tells you whether companies still feel
like this is something that they need to
offer and increasingly the answer is no
so if you look at linkedin's data a year
ago about 20 of the listings on LinkedIn
were for fully remote positions one in
five well now that number is about 12 so
you're talking more like one in eight
positions the demand for those roles is
still very high I mean LinkedIn tells me
that slightly more than half of the
applications that come in on its
platform are for those remote positions
so people really are hungry for that
remote flexibility but of course what
that tells you is that they're very very
competitive right right and companies
feel like they have a little bit more
leverage they're able to say this is an
in-office job or at least this is a
hybrid job where there is some face time
required and although people are
clamoring for the roles there just
aren't enough open positions to go
around now we're also entering warm
weather months you know before the
pandemic nobody thought twice about
being cooped up in an office during the
summer but after remote work in 2020
2021 and most of 2022 that could be hard
for some workers to go back to No Doubt
what I see companies doing is kind of
offering modified versions of that I
mean summer Fridays were a thing before
the pandemic there were companies that
would say well we'll cut out early by
policy not like sneaking away from your
desk at one o'clock we'll actually end
our work day around lunchtime on Friday
I do see some companies bringing back
that benefit and I also see companies
saying we're going to be sort of an
office first model but we will also
offer you the freedom to work for
extended periods of time from a remote
location at some point during the year
and a lot of people of course will
choose to do that during the summer so
you might say for two or three weeks you
can go travel someplace maybe a week of
it is a proper vacation and maybe the
rest of it is a remote work we do see
that kind of flexibility I think what
managers are trying to get back control
of is this idea that that's going to be
the norm now all right but it's not just
being able to do your work in your
favorite slippers or getting dinner
ready at a reasonable hour for many
workers there are real personal finance
benefits to being able to work remotely
how are companies navigating that one of
the things icjr is companies saying you
need to be in the office but not
necessarily the 8 10 12 hour day that
you were before and that's a big
difference for folks right because some
of the frustration that workers had is
let's just say commute time well if
company says all right we need you to
come into the office today but you don't
have your first in-person meeting until
11 A.M well maybe you can start your
work day at home and wait out the rush
hour traffic and then come in at a time
that's better for you or at the other
end of the day you need to pick up your
child from daycare or school at three
o'clock and instead of having to pay for
after school child care okay go ahead
and do that you gotta duck out of the
office this afternoon go pick up your
kid save a few bucks on that and then
log back in when you get a little bit
later so what I see is companies saying
yes you do have to be in the building
but we can be a little bit more flexible
on exactly when during the day those
hours happen all right that's Wall
Street Journal on the clock columnist
Callum Borchers Callum thanks so much
for being with us glad to be with you Jr
and that's it for your money briefing
this week your money briefing is
produced by mohsin Ali our supervising
producer is Melanie Roy and our
executive producer is Chris zinsley I'm
your host J.R Whalen thanks for
listening and have a great weekend
[Music]
thank you